la terrible épreuve du coton tige un
classique bien connu des téléspectateurs
de fort boyard vivre les expériences du
célèbre jeu télévisé
c'est désormais possible à france
miniature le parc élan courtois a
inauguré sa nouvelle attraction en
présence des vedettes de l'émission tous
qui a exposé c'est vraiment serré elle
enfin quand on reconnaît vraiment nos
clés on reconnaît vraiment les indices
les cryptides la télé avec le père
fouras vraiment outillés quoi c'est
super les enfants sont contents s'amuse
bien fait des petits traits attraction
accueillis par le père fouras les
visiteurs sont invités à tester leur
adresse et leurs neurones dans la salle
du conseil
bâtonnets empilage les jeux du fort sont
mis à disposition sous l'oeil attentif
des maîtres avec cette quinzième
animations le parc diversifie son offre
espère attirer un public plus large
on a trouvé un parallèle entre france
miniature et fort boyard les deux
émissions et le parc sont nées à la même
période 1990 pour l'émission de fort
boyard 1991 pour france miniature et on
partage le même public les
téléspectateurs duo forts sont les
visiteurs de france miniature sont avant
tout des familles avec enfants sur un
programme aussi fédérateur que fort
boyard je pense qu'on va aussi pouvoir
aller capter nos moniteurs pour défier
le maître du fort rendez vous le 1er
avril pour la saison 2010 780 mille
visiteurs sont attendus
mais tout ça france miniature c'est
super